[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle séance de questions
d'actualité au sénat
ça commence dans dix minutes à 15 heures
précisément et au menu une dizaine de
questions encore une fois tout consacré
aux kobe de 19 et à ses conséquences
en attendant je suis avec le président l
ère de la commission des affaires
sociales alain milon bonjour un jour
alain milon je précise que vous êtes
également médecin d'abord que vous
inspirez bien les derniers
rebondissements concernant l'hydroxyde
chloroquine à passer de remède miracle
un médicament dangereux pour les
autorités sanitaires et finalement donc
interdite pour soigner le coc vide
aujourd'hui
pas grand chose j'ai toujours estimé que
si les désaccords pouvait exister dans
le monde politique et devraient être
publics afin qu'ils la démocratie puisse
s'exprimer
j'ai toujours estimé que les désaccords
en matière scientifique devait rester
entre les scientifiques de manière à ne
pas perturber la population alors ça n'a
pas été le cas
or ça n'a pas du tout été le cas et je
trouve que c'est extrêmement dommage et
dommageable pour les scientifiques en
particulier donc l'hydroxyde chloroquine
seul est inefficace dans le traitement
du copine c'est une évidence
associé à des antibiotiques en début de
traitement certains professeurs disent
que c'est efficace d'autres disent que
non il semblerait qu'à la suite de
l'article paru dans l'ancêtre qui n'est
pas n'importe quoi dans le monde
scientifique il gravit la scientifique
le ministre ait décidé que cette ce
produit ne doit plus être utilisé dans
le cadre du traitement du coït 19 et on
ne peut donc qu accepter cette décision
dans la mesure où elle est quand même
provoqué par des recherches
particulièrement sérieuses et c'est un
peu dommage pour vous que on est
autorisée ce traitement auparavant bien
qu'est ce que vous en dites
c'est le traitement n'a pas été
autorisée il a été mis en place par le
professeur raoul d'abord et par des
médecins ensuite dans le cadre de la
liberté de prescription des médecins qui
doivent soigner en conscience et qui le
font et qui l'ont fait donc en
conscience y'avait pas d'autoriser
particulière pour le covin en
particulier mais comme certains
estimaient qu'il était efficace certains
ont estimé qu'ils pouvaient l'utiliser
alors également alain milon vous allez
probablement présidé la commission d'
enquête sur la gestion de la crise
ducobu de 19
d'abord ce que vous vous le confirmer le
probablement mais probablement oui
qu'est-ce qui est prévu en tout cas si
rien ne change ça n'a rien changé pour
l'instant donc normalement c'est bien
vous ce matin le président du groupe la
république en marche au sénat françois
patriat a estimé qu'une commission
denquête et dénaturé quand elle devient
une arme politique s à craindre avec
cette commission denquête jeu je pense à
partir du moment où on est en position
d'accusé on estime toujours que ce que
font les autres c'est pour accuser un
peu plus donc monsieur patriat
de ce côté là ne fait que défendre sa
position qui n'est pas obligatoirement
une bonne position puisque la commission
denquête se fait aussi à l'assemblée
nationale et que la présidente de la
commission de coordination nationale
doit être une république en marche n'a
aucune raison donc qu'il n'y ait pas
d'autres commission denquête il se fasse
par ailleurs sachant que de toute façon
l'objet est de savoir pourquoi il ya eu
des défaillances
pourquoi il y a eu des des
désorientations et des discours
différents suivant les autorités qui
dirigent le pays est l'objet est ensuite
de savoir comment il faut faire
autrement et mieux par la suite
qu'est ce qui doit être au coeur de vos
travaux pour vous la gestion des masques
bruno retailleau la semaine dernière en
réagissant aux propos d'emmanuel macro
qui disait qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
pénurie avait estimé lui que c'était un
mensonge
pour l'instant j'ai pas les éléments
suffisants pour dire ça moi de mon côté
il ya eu à mon avis a eu deux gros
problèmes la gestion du manque de
matériel masque en particulier mais
aussi respirateur et puis la gestion de
l'information et en particulier de
l'information dans les ehpad
c'est un c'est un des grands scandales
de ce qui a pu se passer au niveau des
personnes âgées en particulier en milieu
hospitalier et en milieu des pâtes donc
il ya deux grandes orientations qui
pourront être prises c'est pas à moi de
décider mais qui pourront être prises
dans ce souvent identifiés en tout cas
vous personnellement que j'identifie le
manque de gestion antérieure et pendant
des différents types de matériels dont
les masques et les épargnes une toute
dernière question alain milon est ce que
vous êtes favorable à l'application stop
qu'ovide qui est jugée indispensable par
les uns trop intrusive par les autres et
qui va faire l'objet d'un débat ce soir
au sénat cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale
alors il y a deux positions possibles ou
la position de ceux qui disent il faut
protéger la liberté individuelle et la
position de ceux qui disent il faut
protéger la défense sanitaire
moi je fais partie de ceux qui disent
faut de la sécurité sanitaire peut être
un petit peu au détriment de la sécurité
personnelle de la liberté personnelle
sauf que si on ne met pas cette
surveillance on a une crise importante
on fait du confinement et là on prive
complètement la liberté personnelle ne
vous y être favorables merci beaucoup
alain milon d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et à présent je vais
accueillir le président de la commission
des lois
philippe bas philippe bas pour commencer
bonjour je vais commencer par vous poser
la même question car alain milon sur
cette application stop qu'ovide alain
milon est plutôt favorable à la sécurité
sanitaire face à la question éventuelle
de l'intrusion dans la liberté
individuelle
est-ce que vous aujourd'hui vous êtes
favorable à l'application stop qu'ovide
nous allons avoir le débat ce soir nous
avons auditionné vous a été le ministre
ce matin c'était la deuxième fois que
nous le faisions nous avons pris
connaissance de deux avis successifs de
la commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés
on ne s'avance pas dans ce domaine à la
légère parce que la portée de cette
application faut pas que ce soit un
gadget non plus or on veut savoir si
réellement en fonction du nombre de
personnes qui utiliseront l'application
sera un effet concret positive et on
veut s'assurer aussi que les garanties
sur la protection de vos données
personnelles
de votre vie privée seront bien apporter
nous pensons son second point qu'on a
vraiment beaucoup progressé sur le
premier au fond bien le juge de paix ce
seront nos concitoyens est ce que oui ou
non c'est l'application est disponible
est ce qu'ils l'utiliseront étant
entendu que s'ils l'utilisent
ils ont quand même beaucoup de garanties
qu'il n'y a aucune donnée qui ne sortira
de leurs ordiphones c'est-à-dire
smartphone pour utiliser le langage
courant
c'est ce qui inquiète et le plus des
gens ils ne veulent pas inquiète encore
mais bien sûr il y aura encore une
centralisation des données que ça reste
inquiétant pour nos libertés
jusque c'est pour ça que les allemands
vont plutôt sur un autre modèle
alors chaque modèle a ses avantages et
ses inconvénients
le système français nous permet au moins
de préserver notre souveraineté
numérique
c'est un point que nous prendrons en
considération avant de nous prononcer ce
soir mais ce que je ne voudrais pas au
fond c'est arrivé à un système où il y
aurait tellement peu de personnes qu'ils
utiliseraient que ce ne serait pas très
utile et l'idée que au fond comme on a
voulu que le moins possible d'
informations qui transitent par ces
cette application on risque de se
retrouver avec des fausses alertes c'est
à dire vous avez été pendant 15 minutes
dos à dos avec quelqu'un à moins d'un
mètre ou vous portiez des masques je ne
sais pas mais on va vous le signaler
huit jours après sans vous dire quand
avec qui et où
parce que nous n'avons pas voulu mettre
dans le système d information nationale
du coup il est possible pour vous alerte
alors qu' il n'y avait aucun danger
craignez vous que cette application
puisse être utilisé à d'autres fins et
le cas de votre collègue loïc hervé qui
est lui-même d'air membre de la cnil
il a cette crainte mais il faut avoir
toutes les craintes pour les gains poser
des garanties mais il me semble que
le travail qui a été fait par la
commission nationale de l'informatique
et des libertés justement a permis
d'apporter beaucoup de réponses qui
sécurise le dispositif au fond si ce
dispositif ne marche pas ce coup ci au
moins aura-t-il été expérimentée et nous
pourrons ajouter à l'arsenal des mesures
que nous pourrions être amenés à prendre
s'il ya un jour une autre épidémie
si les parlementaires s'y opposent
cedrico a bien dit que l'application est
bien elle n'existerait pas ne serait pas
utilisée ça veut dire que ce vote même
s'il n'est pas contraignant il est très
important aujourd'hui c'est une sorte
d'hommage que le gouvernement fait au
parlement
au fond quand il ya des responsabilités
délicate à prendre même s'il a le droit
de les prendre tout seul
ils préfèrent de plus en plus faire
voter le parlement pour se conforter
nous n'allons pas le décourager de
passer par le parlement aussi souvent
que possible alors même que sa tentation
demeure parfois de nous demander
l'autorisation de légiférer par
ordonnance d'une manière qui est
vraiment trop extensive en ce moment oui
justement le sénat a réduit de moitié le
nombre d'ordonnancés qui est prévu dans
le projet de loi actuellement débattu
dans l'hémicycle certains ont appelé
projet de loi fourre-tout gloubi boulga
vous justifiez pas que vous ne pensez
pas que c'est les ordonnances se
justifier dans le contexte d'urgence
actuelle l'abri si nous n'avons voulu
conserver des ordonnances c'est à dire
le pouvoir de faire la loi donnait au
gouvernement ce qui est quand même une
dérogation à la constitution nous
n'avons voulu le faire que quand il y
avait urgence et nous avons constaté
d'une certaine façon que le projet de
loi du gouvernement profiter un peu de
la situation pour essayer d'avoir les
mains libres dans le plus de domaines
possibles et nous répondons non notre
rôle à nous représentation nationale
sénat assemblée nationale c'est de voter
la loi
de temps en temps on accepte de vous
faire faire des ordonnances mais il faut
qu'il y ait de bonnes raisons il faut
qu'il y ait de bonnes raisons vous êtes
satisfait de ce qui est en train de se
passer dans l'hémicycle à ce que
l'exécutif en train d'évoluer lui dans
ses positions
il avait déjà accepté de réduire oui
lors de la lecture à l'assemblée vous
reconnaître que l'exécutif a commencé à
acheminer vers nous des l'assemblée
nationale et continuent à le faire ce
qui justifie
de plus fort notre démarche est bien
merci beaucoup philippe bas d'avoir
répondu à mes questions on va rejoindre
dans un instant la séance puisque d'un
instant à l'autre va débuter cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement c'est en ce qu'il ya c'est
poursuivi un tout au long du confinement
du déconfinement et qui une nouvelle
fois va être très largement consacrée à
la question de l'épidémie de kovy 19
noté qu'il y avait bien une dizaine de
questions qui sont au menu aujourd'hui
sur des thèmes très divers cela va de
l'agriculture à la question de
l'assurance chômage à une question posée
par la gauche qui jugent notamment et
bien qu'il faudrait une abrogation
totale de cette réforme
parmi les autres questions au programme
mais il y aura également le plan de
relance franco-allemand pour l'europe et
enfin également une question sur les
emplois aidés ou encore les municipales
tout de suite on prend la direction de
l'hémicycle où gérard larcher est en
train de s'exprimer
[Musique]
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement sous le format adapté nous
avons
sauf orientation différente au point de
vue sanitaire
à partir du 2 juin prochain
je renvoie chaque président de groupe le
soin d'informer éléments de leur gros ce
qui permettra plus de collègues de
participer à nos séances rsa lui et ceux
qui sont nos collègues qui ont accepté
d'être présents dans là dans les
tribunes du public qui sont
naturellement comptabilisés comme
présent et que je vois y compris un
président de groupe qui est
naturellement et tobago ce n'est donc je
les salue ce qui démontre la volonté de
l'ensemble des collègues de s'engager
respect des règles sanitaires je
rappelle que pour sortir c'est le tour
de l'hémicycle et pour les sénateurs et
pour le gouvernement c'est le bas de
l'hémicycle chacun respectera ses gestes
barrières qu'on ne doit pas oublier y
compris depuis le 11 mai dernier
la séance est retransmis sur public
sénat et sur notre site internet
la parole est à notre collègue richard
yung pour le groupe de la république en
marche
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues le plan de
500 milliards d'euros proposé la semaine
dernière par la chancelière allemande et
le président français doivent permettre
doit permettre au pays de l'union de
relancer leur économie gravement touché
par la pandémie
cette initiative exceptionnelle par son
ampleur a une signification profonde qui
est la solidarité entre les pays de
l'union et nous devons saluer ici le
courage de la chancelière merkel dit
engagé son pays
une des difficultés pour la commission
et pour sa présidente madame von der
leyen et de trouver l'articulation entre
ce fonds de relance et la finalisation
du cadre financier pluriannuel le but
j'ai de l'union pour la période 20 21 27
il ne faut pas qu'il soit un prétexte ce
plan de relance pour diminuer le budget
européen et il devra respecter les
priorités que sont l'europe verte et le
numérique
il appelle aussi des propositions
certainement forte dans le domaine des
ressources propres
certains pays dits les frugaux pourrait
leur donner d'autres non mais on les
appelle les frugaux ils y sont hostiles
ils ne veulent pas de mutualisation du
solidarité seulement des prêts
remboursables
alors même que leur situation économique
n'est guère plus florissante que la
nôtre et qu'il dépend très largement des
exportations les négociations d'ici le
prochain conseil européen vont être
rudes pour le les convaincre de se
ranger derrière le plan de relance un
plan de relance réellement solidaire la
commission européenne l'allemagne la
france doivent les convaincre de
participer à ce plan et il reste de
nombreux problèmes à résoudre les clés
de répartition les secteurs concernés
les modalités de remboursement
madame la ministre pouvez vous nous
faire un état des discussions en cours
qu'elles première analyse faites vous
des propositions de la commission qui
viennent d'être entre rendu public il ya
une heure à peu près avec 750 milliards
donc plus que le plan initial
constitue-t-elle une bonne base pour
bâtir un compromis fructueux pour vous
répondre la parole est aux ministres de
l'économie et des finances monsieur
bruno le maire vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur richard
yung avec cette proposition de plan de
relance
la commission européenne frappent fort
et elle frappe juste elle se montre à la
hauteur des responsabilités historiques
qui étaient les siennes engagé la
relance économique de l'ensemble des
pays européens confrontés à la crise
économique la plus grave de leur
histoire et le faire sur la base d'un
plan de relance verte
ce plan il reprend l'intégralité des
propositions qui ont été faites par la
chancelière angela merkel et par le
président de la république
je pense que ce doit être un motif de
fierté pour nous tous
de voir que l'accord franco-allemand
négocié par le président de la
république et la chancelière a été
intégralement repris par la commission
européenne et a servi de base à ce plan
500 milliards d'euros sur la base pour
la première fois de l'histoire
européenne d'une levée de dette commune
qui nous garantit un taux d'intérêt le
plus raisonnable possible et à cette
proposition franco allemande
la présidente de la commission
européenne ajoute 250 milliards d'euros
de prêts soit 750 milliards d'euros au
total qui s'ajoute à l'accord conclu
entre les ministres des finances le 9
avril dernier 540 milliards d'euros soit
au total un plan de relance verte de
1300 milliards d'euros pour l'ensemble
des pays européens
c'est une proposition majeure qui
montrent que l'europe est au rendez vous
de l'histoire de ces 1300 milliards
d'euros 500 milliards donc de dépenses
budgétaires directes dont la france
devrait bénéficier directement à hauteur
d'environ 40 milliards d'euros 40
milliards d'euros pour nous aider à
financer les plans de relance sectoriels
le plan de relance tourisme annoncée par
le premier ministre il y a quelques
semaines le plan de relance de
l'automobile annoncés hier par le
président de la république
le plan de relance de l'aéronautique que
nous allons présenter d'ici quelques
jours
ça va nous aider à financer les dépenses
de santé de rénovation de l'hôpital qui
sont indispensables
ça va aider tous les états européens à
financer leur propre relance
l'investissement dans l'innovation et
dans les nouvelles technologies
j'appelle donc tous les états européens
sans exception y compris des quatre
frugaux à soutenir ce plan de la
commission européenne merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue yvon collin pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole merci merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question va regrouper sans doute celle
de richard yung la semaine dernière la
france et l'allemagne ont dévoilé une
proposition de plan de relance à hauteur
de 16 5 milliards sur la base d'un
emprunt communautaire dans le contexte
de récession dramatique qui guettent nos
économies
cette initiative franco allemande est
une nécessité
et tout doit être mis en oeuvre pour
qu'elle aboutisse elle est nécessaire
pour l'europe car soyons honnêtes le
plan de relance de la commission
européenne dont une partie est fondée
sur des prêts et des effets de levier ne
suffira pas à amortir la récession ne
soyons pas dupes
ce plan est aussi une nécessité pour
l'allemagne qui on le sait tire sa
croissance des exportations qu'elle fait
pour 100 milliards aux états unis 100
milliards avec la chine mais aussi et
surtout pour ce 1 5 milliard par an avec
l'union européenne
comme le déclare jean-pierre chevènement
pas d'inquiétude les allemands ne seront
pas la branche sur laquelle ils sont
assis
cet accord franco-allemand est donc je
le répète bienvenus d'autant plus que la
décision de la cour constitutionnelle
allemande castro sur la légalité de la
politique monétaire de la banque
centrale européenne avait jeté un froid
mais même en grand froid je rappellerai
que cette décision remet en cause la
solidarité des dettes par le biais
monétaire le choix franco allemande une
approche budgétaire pour soutenir les
pays endettés pourraient marquer
peut-être un tournant ce plan
qu'incarnerait t-il en effet la
solidarité tant attendu par les états
membres les plus fragilisées par les
conséquences économiques de la crise
kovy 19 ouvre-t-il en fait la voie à la
mutualisation des dettes que berlin
avait toujours refusé jusque là enfin
monsieur le ministre est il une réponse
à la décision de la cour
constitutionnelle allemande qui aurait
pu affaiblir la politique économique
européenne et mettre en péril la zone
euro je vous remercie
quand vous répondre la parole est hideux
l'économie et des finances monsieur
bruno le maire monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs et 7 heures
monsieur le sénateur yvon collin
pourquoi est ce que cette proposition la
commission européenne est historique et
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle marque une
avancée majeure dans l'infirmation de
l'union européenne sur la scène
internationale d'abord par l'ampleur des
sommes qui sont mises sur la table je
leur dise 540 milliards d'euros au
niveau des ministres des finances 500
milliards d'euros deux propositions
franco-allemandes 250 milliards d'euros
de prêts qu'ils s'y ajoutent 1300
milliards d'euros pour la relance chaque
citoyen européen va comprendre que
l'union européenne nous permet de nous
sauver de la crise économique sans
précédent que nous connaissons
historique par l'ampleur
historique aussi parce que à l'origine
de cette proposition
il y a le couple franco-allemand et nous
tous ici je pense que nous sommes
convaincus que le moteur de l'union
européenne ce qui permet de faire
avancer des choses de casser des
plafonds de verre de progresser dans
l'intégration européenne et donc de nous
protéger face aux menaces
internationales
ce sont les propositions franco
allemandes c'est l'accord qui a été
conclu entre le président de la
république française et la chancelière
allemande
la troisième raison pour laquelle ce
projet est historique c'est comme vous
l'avez très bien dit monsieur le
sénateur pour la première fois la
première fois nous acceptons une
mutualisation des dettes sur un projet
de financement de dépenses budgétaires
c'est intéressant financièrement parce
que ça permet d'avoir le taux d'intérêt
le plus faible possible
c'est intéressant financièrement parce
qu'on étale le remboursement sur une
trentaine d'années et c'est un geste
politique majeure un geste de solidarité
oui nous allons donner plus à ceux qui
ont été touchés le plus par la crise du
cours navires us oui nous allons donner
plus à l'espagne et l'italie
eh bien ça devrait être un motif de
fierté pour nous tous parce que ça veut
dire que nous avons aidé ceux des états
qui sont les plus en difficulté et oui
les états rembourseront en fonction
uniquement de leurs capacités
financières de leurs capacités
économiques
il y aura bien un transfert budgétaire
et au lieu de pousser des hauts cris en
disant que c'est scandaleux qu'il y ait
un transfert budgétaire face à une crise
comme celle là on devrait plutôt dire
chapeau bas et fierté pour tous parce
que enfin la solidarité en europe n'est
plus simplement un mot mais un principe
est un acte
monsieur colin
la parole est à d'autres collectifs aux
oubliettes pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes devait
la parole président monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues votre gouvernement a demandé
au préfet de la vendée d'organiser avec
ses responsables la réouverture du parc
de loisirs du puy du fou le 2 juin
cette décision aurait été prise lors
d'un conseil de défense et de sécurité
nationale le choix de cette instance
tient sans doute à la nature des minutes
des manifestations qui se déroulent dans
ce parc je pense par exemple aux combats
de gladiateurs
nous sommes très heureux que l'état
depuis son sommet donne ainsi la
possibilité de retravailler aux nombreux
professionnels de la culture du puy du
fou
notre peine est en revanche immense pour
les artistes les intermittents du
spectacle les auteurs les compositeurs
tous ces professionnels sur lesquels
repose le rayonnement culturel de notre
pays qui se sentent totalement abandonné
vivent avec angoisse
l'incertitude du lendemain et attendent
de votre gouvernement une aide
vigoureuse pour les aider à résister à
la crise qui risque de les emporter avec
eux ce sont des milliers de structures
culturelles qui risque de disparaître
tout ce réseau patiemment construit
pendant des décennies a fait de notre
pays
la première destination touristique
mondiale son activité économique
mobilise 2,4 pour cent de la population
active est presque 50 milliards d'euros
il a fait de la culture un service
public et à donner à nos concitoyens les
moyens de leur lait vation artistique et
de laure émancipation un tube
intellectuelle
ce réseau d'une grande fragilité risque
aujourd'hui d'être emporté par la crise
alors que nous aurions tellement besoin
de culture pour la surmonter
il ne se passe pas une semaine sans que
votre gouvernement n'annonce des plans
de sauvetage de plusieurs milliards
d'euros
la culture doit elle
se contenter de proclamation lyrique et
de vaines promesses
monsieur le ministre à quand un plan de
sauvetage de la culture prendre la
parole et communistes de la culture que
franck riester
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je peux pas vous
laisser dire que le gouvernement n'est
pas au rendez vous pour le secteur de la
culture dès le début de la crise qui
touche vous avez raison avec beaucoup de
dureté le secteur de la culture le
gouvernement est au rendez vous pour
faire en sorte que les mesures
transversales annoncée par le ministre
de l'économie et des finances sous
l'autorité du premier ministre puisse
être accessible au secteur de la culture
le fonds de solidarité les prêts
garantis par l'état les exonérations de
charges sociales les dispositifs de
report d'un certain nombre de charges
fiscales les dispositifs d'accès au
chômage partiel bref tous ces
dispositifs qui ont été accessibles au
secteur de la culture et le président de
la république a été très clair il ya un
peu plus de deux semaines maintenant dix
ans que les arts et la culture était
pour lui une priorité en annonçant très
clairement que nous devions protéger
celles et ceux qui sont le ciment de la
vie culturelle dans les territoires que
sont les artistes et techniciens de
l'audiovisuel du cinéma et du spectacle
vivant en prolongeant leurs droits
jusqu'à fin août 2021 en annonçant très
clairement qu'il souhaitait réarmer
financièrement le centre national de la
musique qui vient d'être créée notamment
grâce au vote du sénat en faisant en
sorte de doter l'ifsic et la banque du
secteur de la culture de presque 100 5
millions d'euros 85 millions de l'état
et 20 millions de la banque des
territoires bref un ensemble de mesures
à la fois d'urgence et d'accueil
d'accompagnement à la reprise pour
permettre à ce secteur si durement
touchée de pouvoir être protégés et
accompagner dans la reprise
cette reprise elle passe par des aides
financières mais elle passe aussi par la
possibilité de pouvoir recommencer à
vivre de pouvoir recommencer à mettre
des artistes devant leur public
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
travaillons à faire en sorte que demain
puissent être pris un certain nombre de
décisions pour aller peut-être plus loin
dans le déconfinement en matière de
spectacle
ils vont en matière de cinéma ou en
matière de grands musées et aux
monuments historiques
bref le gouvernement est mobilisé pour
accompagner ce secteur si important pour
nous tous que son quai le secteur des
arts et la culture
si la parole est à notre collègue
claudine lepage
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
j'avais la parole monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres la crise
sanitaire que nous traversons entraîne
dans son sillage et une crise et social
et économique sans précédent si le
mécanisme de chômage partiel a jusque-là
servi de filet social à la crise
économique
votre décision de le diminuer conjugué
au durcissement de l'accès à
l'indemnisation imposé par la réforme de
l'assurance chômage entré partiellement
en vigueur fin 2019 l'esc reims une
trique précarisation grandissante de
nombreux travailleurs les travailleurs
les plus fragiles ceux qui avant la
crise occupaient un emploi précaire et
les travailleurs des secteurs les plus
sévèrement touchés par la crise
sanitaire déjà durement impactée par les
conséquences économiques de l'épidémie
de comics 19 le seront davantage encore
avec la réforme de l'assurance chômage
je pense notamment aux extras dans le
secteur de la restauration aux
travailleurs de l'événementiel et aux ex
auxiliaires de vie et aides soignantes
auprès des personnes âgées
mais la liste n'est pas exhaustive la
décision de reporter au mois de
septembre
le deuxième volet de la réforme de
l'indemnisation du chômage n'est donc
pas suffisante car c'est l'ensemble de
la réforme qui pose problème est qu'il
faut définitivement abrogée
madame la ministre la seule volonté qui
anime cette réforme est de satisfaire un
double objectif comptable en réalisant
des économies budgétaires au détriment
de l'indemnisation des chômeurs et en
agissant artificiellement à la baisse
sur les statistiques du chômage
c'est cette même logique comptable qui a
mené l'hôpital public dans la situation
alarmante que nous connaissons face à
laon
pleurs de cette crise cette réforme
comme celle des retraites doit être
abandonnée madame la ministre
quand allez vous enfin annoncer
l'abrogation pure et simple de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage on vous
répond de la parole et avaient l'air de
la milice du travail la ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice corinne lepage
d'abord merci d'avoir salué l'importance
de l'activité partielle qui a permis
massivement de protéger 12 millions de
salariés 1 million d'entreprises éviter
les défaillances permettent aux
compétences d'être conservés et
sauvegarder l'emploi
néanmoins nous sommes donc conscients
que la crise sanitaire se prolonge par
une crise économique et sociale d'une
ampleur imprévisible il ya quelques mois
je vous rappelle que il ya trois mois
exactement nous pouvions nous réjouir
d'une baisse du chômage puisque le
chômage était à 8,1 pour cent son plus
bas taux depuis 11 ans et que
l'apprentissage est en pleine
progression et pour 16%
ça nous semble loin et pourtant c'était
il ya pas si longtemps alors de ce
contexte là où outre le chômage partiel
ce que nous avons fait c'est prendre des
mesures d'urgence immédiate pour
protéger les plus vulnérables dans le
contexte de la crise et du confinement
dès le 14 avril nous avons pris un
décret qui a permis de d'une part
prolonger les droits de tous ceux qui
arrivaient en fin de droits à
l'assurance chômage
vous aurez d'ailleurs l'occasion de
prolonger d'amplifier cet élément demain
en votant je l'espère un amendement
proposé par le gouvernement pour
prolonger les droits des intermittents
du spectacle jusqu'au 31 août 2021
deuxièmement nous avons aussi prévu que
la période d'affiliation pour calculer
droit passe de 24 à 27 mois c'est déjà
opérationnel ensuite nous avons ouvert
les quatre démissions légitime pour ceux
qui avaient démissionné juste avant le
confinement
nous avons aussi suspendu la
dégressivité les mesures de calcul du
salaire journalier de référence à vous
m'interrogez pour la suite
eh bien nous prolonger choses dans
l'ordre notre boussole c'est le
pragmatisme l'efficacité économique la
justice sociale et les discussions de la
suite de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage seront prises après discussion
avec les partenaires sociaux dans les
semaines qui viennent
merci la parole de notre collègue à la
marque
pour le groupe les indépendants ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics
vous savez l'importance des communes
vous êtes maire et l'impôt pts et
l'impact de leurs investissements pour
l'économie afin d'accélérer précisément
leur investissement beaucoup de maires
souhaitent une modification de
l'attribution du fctva afin de permettre
la récupération de la tva et ce dès la
première année
actuellement le fctva et verser deux ans
après la réalisation de la dépense aux
collectivités n'ayant pas confiance
convention avec l'état au titre du
dispositif plan de relance pour celles
qui ont respecté les engagements du plan
de relance le versement est effectué un
an après enfin pour les opci à fiscalité
propre et les communes nouvelles
le remboursement intervient l'année même
de la réalisation de la dépense
or nombreuses sont les communes qui ne
disposent pas d'une trésorerie
suffisante pour assurer le financement
de certains investissements aussi
doivent-elles contracté des prêts relais
qui leur permettront en particulier de
couvrir les dépenses liées à la tva
d'où un coût supplémentaire pour ces
collectivités cela constitue un
véritable frein à l'initiative locale et
s'avérer pénalisant dans la mesure où
les élus risque à long terme de
s'interdire toute volonté de
développement des équipements locaux
entraînant ainsi une dévitalisation
notamment dans les campagnes monsieur le
ministre il apparaît indispensable de
préserver la capacité financière de nos
communes afin qu'elle soit en mesure non
seulement de continuer d'assurer les
services essentiels à la population mais
également de relancer les
investissements indispensables au
soutien du tissu économique local afin
d'atténuer le choc financier subi par
les collectivités locales les modalités
relatives au fctva pourrait être
modifiée en faveur d'une récupération de
la tva dès la première année notamment
pour les communes ayant effectué un
investissement
au delà d'un seuil de dépense qu'il vous
reste bien sûr à définir par exemple de
5000 euros
pouvez vous nous indiquer les mesures
que le gouvernement entend prendre pour
aller dans le sens préconisé par ses
élus de terrain merci pour vous répondre
la parole et au ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics
c'est gérald darmanin merci monsieur le
président monsieur sénateurs vous avez
raison les collectivités le
quelles sont celles qui investissent le
plus et qui soutiennent l'économie
bien sûr de l'ensemble du territoire il
ne faut pas malgré la crise qui touche
durement l'ensemble du pays
il ne faut pas faire les erreurs du
passé et baisser les dotations moment où
nous devons justement rétablir les
finances publiques et avoir une
solidarité nationale sur tous les
aspects que vous connaissez dans les
divers projets vote finances que nous
avons proposées c'est pour ça que le
premier ministre après la décision ne
pas s'engager vers la baisse des
dotations et de discuter avec les
associations d'élus chacune gouro
sébastien lecornu ollier du soft et moi
même avons eu plusieurs réunions avec
tous tes associations d'élus et première
annonce que ce premier ministre réunira
vendredi à l'hôtel matignon
les communes les associations autour des
communes et le bloc intercommunale bien
sûr les départements et puis l'outre-mer
qui est très spécifique évidemment dans
les difficultés que nous connaissons
évidemment devant les difficultés les
communes et les collectivités locales de
manière générale ne sont pas toutes
logées à la même enseigne seulement 30 %
de leurs recettes sont sensibles à
l'activité économique mais 30 % quand
même et on voit bien que dans les zones
touristiques dont ceux qui touchent des
redevances allant en outre-mer
évidemment l'année prochaine
singulièrement les départements même si
droits de mutation sont concernés cette
année c'est l'année prochaine sans doute
qu'ils seront le plus touchés nous
devons réseau à résoudre ces problèmes
et donc le premier sera ce fait est que
dans le projet de scission ce
rectificatif numéro 3 tel que je m'y
étais engagé devant votre assemblée lors
du plfr numéro deux et numéro un et il y
aura des dispositions relatives aux
collectivités locales
le premier ministre évidemment rendra
les derniers arbitrages après avoir
écouté associons d'élus fctva pourrait
en faire partie c'est 6 milliards dans
la finance que vous avez voté cette
année il ya des avantages et des
inconvénients nous avons missionné un
parlementaire monsieur cazeneuve qui va
rendre son rapport
et qui va apporter des pistes le fct à
peu à faire paris partie pardon avec une
petite difficulté c'est que c'est un one
shot bien sûr puisque si vous avancez
tout la première année se poserait
question de la deuxième année et le
sujet d'investissements sera plus en
2021 encore me semble-t-il que pour 2020
merci la parole notre collègue françois
bonhomme pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre de l'agriculture puisque c'est
de lui que s'adresse cette question ces
derniers mois la crise sanitaire a été
comme un révélateur de nos faiblesses
je pourrais évoquer notre dépendance
vis-à-vis des pays étrangers concernant
la fourniture de médicaments ou de
matériel médical ou encore la course à
l'échalote à laquelle l'état s'est livré
pour se fournir en masques et
médicaments
mettant à nu notre dépendance sanitaires
les pays producteurs se servent en
premier
c'est ainsi et le corps n'avait risque
de le rappeler parfois avec cruauté des
voix se sont alors élevés pour nous dire
que plus jamais ne sera comme avant
selon une formule rituelle est quasi
liturgique et pourtant monsieur le
ministre il est un domaine dans lequel
notre pays a gardé une réelle capacité à
produire c'est l'agriculture et
l'agroalimentaire bien que mal
considérés et souvent mal rémunérés nos
agriculteurs assurent notre indépendance
alimentaire et ce en dépit d'une
concurrence déloyale à laquelle ils sont
confrontés et qui nous fait perdre du
terrain
année après année comme si les erreurs
du passé n'avaient pas servi
la commission européenne vient de
proposer à la fois de baisser de 10% la
surface la superficie des terres
cultivables en france en europe et donc
en france
et de conclure après le c'est à un
accord de libre échange avec le mexique
qui touche précisément aux produits
agricoles le mexique propres aux droits
produire ainsi exporté en europe ce que
les terres européennes ou prendre plus
produire tout cela est parfaitement
absurde
s comme cela monsieur mise que l'on
pourra assurer notre souveraineté
alimentaire et permettre aux
agriculteurs de vivre de leur métier ou
encore en faisant venir par avion des
produits alimentaires sûrement pas la
france monsieur ministre fera t-elle
jouer donc son droit de veto pour
s'opposer aux accords de libre échange
qui se profile et ferez vous vous mêmes
obstacles à la baisse de la superficie
des terres agricoles pour privilégier la
production locale pour vous répondre la
parole et communistes de l'agriculture
et de l'alimentation monsieur didier
guillaume
non mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bonhomme vous poser
deux questions en fait dans votre
question la première qui concerne la
signature par phil hogan le commissaire
européen d'un accord entre la france et
le mexique
cet accord il est en route depuis des
années l'union européenne a fait ce
choix a au nom du gouvernement à un
mauvais moment c'est pas en pleine crise
du comics usa doit se faire de toute
façon cet accord doit être ratifié par
le parlement
et je ne doute pas que le parlement
regardera les choses de près en effet
dans le cadre de cette crise vont toutes
et tous dit que la souveraineté
alimentaire était absolument
indispensable et qu'il fallait une
certaine relocalisation le président de
la république l'a dit en janvier
il faut que nous travaillons sur une
exception agricoles et agroalimentaires
et alimentaire dans le cadre des
échanges internationaux sur votre
deuxième question et le ch le fait que
la commission ait souhaité est passé de
5% à 10%
les surfaces d'intérêt écologique une
proposition de la commission qui n'est
pas encore validé par les états membres
n'auront pas eu l'occasion d'en parler
je veux d'abord rappelé que les surfaces
d'intérêt écologique sont très
importantes
les murs et les lacs les retenues d'eau
dans nos campagnes font la richesse et
la biodiversité c'est là où la
biodiversité est vraiment très
importante
la commission propose de l'augmenter ne
faut pas avoir peur de l'augmentation du
verdissement de la pac pour
l'alimentation et pour la france dans la
mesure où nous sommes très en avance et
ça mettrait d'autres pays au même niveau
que nous mêmes mais en tout cas dans le
cadre de cette augmentation des surfaces
d'intérêt écologique si elle devait
avoir lieu
alors la france défend absolument de
toutes ses forces un sujet sur lequel
j'avais beaucoup travaillé notamment le
groupe sioniste et républicains de ses
atours montaugé
c'est les paiements pour services
environnementaux qui doit absolument
être là les agriculteurs doivent être
rémunérés lorsqu'ils font plus de
biodiversité
lorsqu'ils font mieux d'agriculture et
lorsqu'ils travaillent pour la
transition agroécologiques je vous
remercie le surnomme mais monsieur
ministre est bien entendu vos propos
généraux mais j'aurais quand même
souhaité d'abord une réaction plus
rapide car la cuisson en france a été
bien discrète et même taciturne de ce
point de vue alors que ça touche
vraiment un secteur
qui est extrêmement porteur important
pour notre pays et puis vous savez que
les instructeurs n'ont plus confiance
malheureusement il se demande même
parfois si votre ministère n'est pas une
succursale du mystère l'environnement ou
encore pire à la remorque de cette
vision parfois technocratique qui nous
viennent la commission pixels
merci la parole est à notre collègue
jean paul prince pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mais mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
dans la lutte contre la maladie du
encore au coronavirus qui mobilise notre
pays localisés l'épidémie et surveiller
ses déplacements sont deux enjeux
cruciaux en premier lieu pour des
raisons sanitaires et en 2d dieu pour
des raisons économiques notamment dans
les zones touristiques le combat contre
la copie de 19 serait plus efficace avec
une meilleure connaissance de la
diffusion du virus sur le territoire et
de l'intensité de l'épidémie d'une
région à l'autre
à cet égard un avis de l'académie des
technologies publié le 19 avril dernier
attire l'attention sur les
renseignements que peuvent fournir les
eaux usées en effet la mesure de la
concentration du génome du virus dans
les eaux usées pourrait permettre de
mieux évaluer le nombre de malades dans
une zone donnée
car le suivi prend en compte les virus
rejetée par la totalité des personnes
porteuses qu'elle soit saine un
symptomatique ou malades
l'information récoltée permettra aux
collectivités locales et aux ars dévalue
avec plus de précision l'état sanitaire
du territoire dont ils ont la
responsabilité
et d'y apporter une réponse adaptée de
plus le coût de telles mesures de suivi
serait le relativement modeste des
mesures de surveillance des eaux usées
ont déjà été annoncés à l'étranger en
france comité d' analyse de recherche et
d'expertisé mis en place par le
président de la république a apporté son
soutien à cette pratique
en conclusion je souhaiterais savoir
monsieur le ministre si le gouvernement
prévoit d'effectuer des prélèvements de
ce type dans le cadre de la lutte contre
l'épidémie ou
ils comptent autorités et les
collectivités locales à le fait pour
vous répondre à la parole et secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur taquet
cherche des yeux mais je vois monsieur
le président merci beaucoup
madame les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur jean-paul
prince je vous remercie pour votre
question effectivement la circulation du
virus suscite et ce à juste titre
beaucoup d'interrogation de beaucoup de
mobilisations aussi de la part de
nombreux acteurs de différents acteurs
dans différents chambre connaissances
que nous avons sur le virus se sont
encore parcellaires on s'en rend compte
effectivement tous les jours et il est
nécessaire d'explorer toutes les pistes
qui sont à notre disposition qui
s'annonce à à nous alors vous avez
évoqué cet avis de l'académie de
technologie il est aussi une étude
française qui a été publiée dans science
qui a montré que la quantification du
virus ce sera ce que 2 dans les eaux
usées pouvait effectivement être un
marqueur de circulation du virus est un
projet aubépines aussi dans le bassin
parisien qui depuis 2015 d'ailleurs en
examinant les eaux de la senne permet de
déceler la circulation du virus de
gastro entérite à l'époque et pourrait
donc être utilement mobilisés pour
autant un indicateur de cette nature en
effet un intérêt pour dire que la
circulation du virus existent dans la
communauté qui est desservi par le
système d'évacuation des eaux mais ne
fait que constater c'est une sorte
d'image un instant donné de cette
circulation à un niveau qui est déjà
élevée puisque on le constate et qui est
déjà en cours c'était un indicateur qui
ne contribue pas donc en tant que tel à
empêcher la circulation du virus il
serait simplement annonciateur d'un taux
de contamination élevée d'un flux
potentiel de malades donc dit autrement
il n'y a rien dans ce type de procédé de
précoce par rapport à la prévention et
cet outil ne continuerait pas au à cette
stratégie de contact racing que nous
développons et que nous mettons en
oeuvre depuis plusieurs jours maintenant
et qui nous semble être un outil bien
plus efficace grâce notamment aux
professionnels libéraux professionnels
de l'assurance maladie vous le savez aux
professionnels de de la rs et puis
demain si les suite au débat que vous
aurez ici dans cette
hémicycle grâce à l'application stop que
vides voilà monsieur le sénateur suppose
pour dire que merci monsieur le ministre
pour dire que les derniers relevés sur
paris ceux d'il ya trois semaines était
de 5 millions de génomes par litre l'a
apparemment ces gens si ils sont
beaucoup nettement moins donc le virus
disparaît de plus en plus merci la
parole est à notre collègue laure darcos
pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre monsieur
le premier ministre
mes collègues philippe bas fourneau
retailleau et hervé marseille viennent
de déposer une proposition de loi pour
organiser dans des conditions
irréprochables second tour des élections
municipales elle a été intégrée à celle
de notre collègue cédric perrin déposé
il ya maintenant plusieurs semaines est
adopté ce matin même par la commission
des lois
cette proposition doit à deux ambitions
adapter les opérations de vote
un contexte épidémique persistant et
faciliter l'établissement des
procurations adapter les opérations de
vote c'est garantir aux électeurs qu'ils
pourront exercer leur droit de vote sans
risque pour eux mêmes ni pour leurs
proches c'est aussi permettre aux
candidats à leurs représentants et aux
membres des bureaux de vote de
participer au déroulement et au
dépouillement du scrutin en toute
sécurité
je ne sollicite ici aucune faveur mais
la considération élémentaires que la
république doit à ses concitoyens
faciliter l'établissement des
procurations c'est permettre à chaque
électeur de détenir deux procurations de
voter pour un des ses parents proches
dans une autre commune de celle où il
réside c'est aussi la possibilité donnée
à une personnes fragiles âgées isolées
ou malades d'établir une procuration à
son domicile
là encore il ne s'agit que de respecter
l'équité républicaine
il n'y a pas de société démocratique
sans le vote citoyen le freiner ou le
tronquée serait un sacrilège
après l'abstention les frustrations du
premier tour ce second tour est attendu
depuis de nombreuses semaines
nous devons vous devez permettre la
participation du plus grand nombre
d'électeurs
nous devons vous devez faire la loi qui
le garantira monsieur le premier
ministre nous avons tout mis en oeuvre
pour adopter un
moins d'une semaine les textes sur
l'état d'urgence sanitaire et sa
prorogation alors ma question est très
simple
êtes vous prêts à utiliser tous les
moyens constitutionnels à votre
disposition pour faire aboutir ces
mesures électorale indispensable avant
le 15 juin afin qu'elles puissent être
mises en oeuvre dans de bonnes
conditions le 28 merci pour vos répondre
la parole et au secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre l'intérieur monsieur laurent
du neige j'avais la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice airs
effectivement aujourd'hui au conseil des
ministres étaient inscrits à l'ordre du
jour le décret de convocation des
électeurs pour le deuxième tour des
élections municipales qui se tiendra le
28 juin qui va concerner un peu plus de
16 millions d'électeurs un peu moins de
2,5 milles commune et cette décision a
été prise par le premier ministre après
évidemment qui a été rendu l'avis du
conseil scientifique le 18 mai dernier
qui a prévu un certain nombre de
conditions sanitaires dans lesquelles le
scrutin de voix devra se tenir à la fois
pour la campagne électorale est bien
évidemment à la fois pour l'organisation
des opérations de vote au moment même où
on se parle je viens d'ailleurs de
quitter cette réunion que je vais
rejoindre aussitôt nous recevons avec le
ministre de l'intérieur des d'autres
ministres les chefs des partis
politiques de notre pays puis nous
aurons une réunion ensuite avec les
associations d'élus pour discuter de ce
que seront ces modalités qui permettront
je reprends vos propos madame la
sénatrice d'organiser ces élections dans
des conditions irréprochables à la fois
en termes juridiques et à la fois en
termes bien évidemment de protection
sanitaire de nos concitoyens alors bien
sûr plusieurs pistes seront évoqués le
fait de faciliter les procurations le
fait de préconiser d'avoir la
possibilité pour les électeurs de
pouvoir porter effectivement un masque
l'aménagement des bureaux de vote comme
nous l'avions fait en partie pour le
premier tour mais d'autres
préconisations est émise par le conseil
scientifique et d'une travaillons
évidemment à la mise en oeuvre de ces
dispositifs alors bien sûr il ya
d'autres demandes
vous en avez cité une très précise qui
est la possibilité d'élargir le champ
d'application juridique des procurations
pas seulement les facilités mais élargir
le champ juridique l'ensemble de ces
questions seront à l'étude
et je puis vous garantir que nous y
attelons dans un esprit d'ouverture mais
aussi de sécurité juridique pour donner
et reprendre l'exemple que vous avez
cités
des procurations je vous rappelle que
juridiquement et les principes qui
s'appliquent et qui veulent que pour une
procuration
il faut qu'en tout moment puisse
vérifier l'identité du mandant de celui
qui donne procuration et en même temps
vérifier son consentement donc c'est à
l'aune de l'ensemble de ces principes
que nous avons eu nous examinerons dans
un esprit de grande ouverture l'ensemble
des discussions fin l'ensemble des
mesures dont découleront les discussions
qui sont actuellement en cours voilà
madame le gouverneur causse merci
monsieur secrétaire d'état vous pensez
bien qu'il ya urgence nous sommes
quasiment nous sommes à un mois
les procurations c'est essentiel il faut
qu'ils aient un plus grand nombre qu'ils
puissent voter savez très bien que
d'emmener d'envoyer nos pj directement à
domicile ou même de faire des
permanences dans certaines communes pour
que les objets puisse récupérer les
procurations
ça nous aidera beaucoup et ça démarre ça
aidera la démocratie merci merci la
parole et l autre collègue annie
guillemot pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresser au ministre de la ville
2010cette 497 mille contrats aidés 2019
plus que 130 milles jugé trop coûteux et
peu utile oui leur remise en cause
drastique et brutale a signifié non
seulement le retour à la précarité pour
beaucoup de jeunes mais aussi la
fragilisation du monde associatif 15 %
de notre population plus de 9 millions
de personnes vivent au dessous du seuil
de pauvreté
or cette triple crise sanitaire
économique et sociale frappe durement
les quartiers où se concentre la
pauvreté pertes d'emplois plus fortes
fracture comme inégalités exacerbée
alors que les besoins parfois ce vito se
sont révélés au grand jour alimentation
logement emploi numérique
l'urgence est de répondre aux
conséquences des plus fragiles
la réactivation des contrats aidés peut
constituer un levier de soutien fort et
rapidement mobilisables ce sont des
milliers de jeunes qui pourraient
travailler dans nos communes et
associations et trouver une première
insertion dans l'emploi tutoré par des
adultes face à la fracture numérique qui
pénalise lourdement les enfants les plus
modestes ses employés seraient bien
utiles à ceux qui ne savent pas
maîtriser cet outil devenu indispensable
madame la ministre regard des besoins
existants dans les écoles les collèges
et de la nécessité de donner un avenir
aux jeunes de ces quartiers le
gouvernement compte-t-il réactiver les
contrastes les contrats aidés
pour me répondre la parole et cavalaire
la ministre du travail
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs dans le sénatrice annie
guillemot depuis trois ans nous menons
une stratégie claire c'est permettent
aussi aux plus vulnérables d'accéder à
l'emploi dans un contexte de reprise
l'emploi qui était fort des créations
d'emplois depuis trois ans et qui
maintenant on doit s'adapter évidemment
un contact nouveau saut perdre de vue
cet objectif nul n'est inemployable il
faut permettre chaque à chacun d'accéder
à l'emploi non pour cela n'ôtera tj
repose sur quatre leviers le premier ce
sont les contrats aidés que nous avons
transformé en parcours emploi
compétences ce qui permettent un
meilleur accès l'emploi qu'est ce que
c'est un parcours en plein compétences
et contrats aidés dans une association
une collectivité locale mais qui
s'appuie sur un triptyque la situation
de travail la formation et
l'accompagnement social et il y en a 90
mille prévus cette année avec une
priorité est évidemment dans les zones
les plus fragiles
la deuxième chose c'est le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
sur lequel nous investissons des sommes
considérables et sur lequel sont
cinquante mille jeunes et 150 mille
demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée
pourront bénéficier cette année 16 %
viennent des quartiers prioritaires de
la ville ce qui est beaucoup plus
évidemment que le poids dans la
population autant viennent d outre-mer
et 8% soit en situation de handicap nous
veillons à la fois ce qu'ils permettent
avec les régions avec qui nous avons
négocié et contractualisés la moitié des
piques
nous prions est-ce qu'ils accèdent à
l'emploi mais aussi que les plus
vénérables soient bien intégrés
troisièmement c'est évidemment le
secteur de l'insertion par l'activité
économique
vous vous rappelez que dans le budget
vous avez voté un milliard d'euros c'est
un investissement qu'on n'a jamais fait
autant dans les yeux pour multiplier les
structures d'entreprises adaptées
d'entreprises d'insertion chantier
d'insertion entreprise d'insertion et
d'ailleurs demain vous aurez l'occasion
de conforter sa aussi en permettant dans
la loi d'urgence que les contrats
d'insertion pour les bénéficiaires
actuels puissent être porté de 24 à 36
mois
c'est très important dans la crise
actuelle parce que leur accès à l'emploi
va être plus difficile
et enfin ce sont les emplois francky
vite vise à lutter contre la
discrimination dans les quartiers
prioritaires de la ville discrimination
raciale
social.le très fréquentes
et aujourd'hui depuis la généralisation
depuis le 1er janvier de cette année du
système d'emploi francs sont plus de
26000 bénéficiaires nous allons
continuer tout au long de l'année 80 %
sont embauchés en cdi alors qu'ils sont
en difficulté
nous ne perdons pas le câble
continueront à niveau merci oui madame
la ministre merci pour ces précisions
mais ma question s'adresse est bien au
ministre de la ville sur la situation
d'ensemble de ces quartiers et vous me
répondez sur des procédures qui existent
déjà
vous avez dit 16% mais ce que je
demandais cd emploi aidé occupé par des
jeunes des quartiers qui est des élèves
les décrocheurs un élève sur dix dans
les quartiers est à l'école en ce moment
c'était faire coup double c'est à dire
des étudiants qui vont pas avoir de jobs
qui en septembre on pas pouvoir
reprendre une année universitaire qui a
gelé décrocheurs qui est dans nos
communes
il y a urgence je me demande aujourd'hui
s'il ya une politique de la ville parce
que les ministres nous répondent tous
dans leurs tiroirs respectifs or il faut
une vue globale aujourd'hui et ce n'est
pas l'ex maire de bron qui vous le dira
qu'il n'a d'ailleurs jamais cumulé bien
avant l'application de la loi parce que
aujourd'hui avec l'augmentation de la
pauvreté
on a quoi aujourd'hui les problèmes des
écoles la pauvreté qui augmente et aussi
la désespérance de ces quartiers il ya
eu un appel des maires de villes de
banlieue il faut aujourd'hui répondre et
ma question s'adresse est donc bien au
ministre de la ville
merci la parole est là notre collègue
pierre b de vienne
pour le groupe de l'union centriste la
parole merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
elle concerne l'intégration d'autres
plateformes de financement participatif
des courbes landing dans le dispositif
des prêts garantis par l'état aux
entreprises
si aujourd'hui le gouvernement s'appuie
uniquement sur les banques pour injecter
des 300 milliards d'euros de prêts
garantis dans l'économie beaucoup
d'entreprises risquent de se retrouver
dans un effet de ciseaux cruelle entre
les échéances à court terme et le manque
de trésorerie pour démarrer la machine
économique passe confinement de plus ces
demandes seront plus nombreuses que les
capacités de traitement des banques
il faudra bien diversifié l'offrant à ce
stade seuls les particuliers et les
fonds elle tiff peuvent souscrire des
prêts émis par les plates formes
dispositif des prêts garantis par l'état
les personnes morales aux excuses de
possibilités alors qu'elles ne sont pas
moins avertis que les personnes
physiques et les formules tiff dans la
filière agroalimentaire en particulier
certains groupes de la grande
distribution ou de la coopération
agricole se sont portés volontaires pour
ce type de financement auprès de
certains de leurs partenaires habituels
l'intérêt de les intégrer paraît donc
évident pour éviter les faillites en
cascade
il pourrait être utile d'élargir le
dispositif de la garantie de l'état aux
entreprises qui financerait une partie
du prêt via des plateformes à des
entreprises de leurs filières qu'elles
connaissent parfaitement
monsieur le ministre est il envisageable
comme en italie que les entreprises qui
prêterait à leurs partenaires dans leur
filière puisse bénéficier de prêts
garantis par l'état au même titre que
les banques des fois le tiff ou les
particuliers pour vous répondre
la parole est aux ministres de
l'économie et des finances monsieur
bruno le maire vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur les prêts garantis par l'état
ces 78 milliards d'euros de prêts qu'ils
ont déjà été accordés à plus de 400
mille entreprises
donc c'est un immense succès qui
répondent aux besoins de trésorerie des
entreprises et qui était voulue par le
premier ministre par le président de la
république puisque nous pouvons monter
jusqu'à 300 milliards d'euros d'encours
pour faire face aux besoins de
trésorerie des entreprises
ce dispositif nous l'avons
juste et à l'origine seules les banques
pouvaient à distribuer ces crédits
désormais effectivement les plates
formes de financement participatif
peuvent aussi accéder à ce type de
dispositif
vous avez parfaitement raison je pense
que ce sera utile qu'elle puisse y
participer
nous l'avons amélioré aussi pour tenir
compte du besoin de certains secteurs
spécifiques et la semaine passée le pré
ministre a annoncé un plan sur le
tourisme l'hôtellerie la restauration et
il a annoncé notamment la mise en place
d'un plan spécifique de financement d'un
prêt spécifique
après saisonniers pour les entreprises
hôtellerie de la restauration qui leur
permet de demander un nouveau prêt de
trésorerie à hauteur des trois meilleurs
mois de l'année 2019
donc si vous êtes un restaurant qui fait
80 % son chiffre entre le mois de juin
et le mois d'août nous prendrons ce
chiffre de référence et ils pourront
demander un prêt à hauteur de 80 % alors
que normalement le plafonnement et à 25%
et je pren ait remboursé que un an plus
tard c'est à dire après la saison 2021
donc c'est une vraie aide très concrète
qui est apportée au secteur de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration du
tourisme pour leur permettre d'anticiper
et de faire face aux difficultés
auxquelles ils sont confrontés
nous avons augmenté aussi la possibilité
pour l'état d'apporter des prêts directs
j'ai sur mon bureau un dossier d'une
entreprise qui s'est vu refuser tous les
prêts qui n'a pas de possibilité
aujourd'hui et qui pourtant est une
entreprise qui me semble saine
nous lui accorderons après directe de
l'état via le fonds de développement
économique et solidaire donc nous avons
je crois diversifié toutes les réponses
pour que face à une crise qui est d'une
ampleur sans précédent
chaque entreprise trouve une réponse en
terme de prêts et en termes de
trésorerie
ce média elle sur le ministre j'entends
votre réponse j'avais d'ailleurs salué
le vote au sénat dans la nuit du 22
avril de l'amendement du gouvernement
qui permettait d'intégrer des
plateformes financement participatif
crowdfunding nos dispositifs des prêts
garantis par l'état actuellement
l'amendement est limitée au plate forme
de prêts participatifs avec le statut
intermédiaire en financement
participatif
qui n'est pas ouverte aux entreprises
non financières personne morale en tant
que financières dans le contexte de la
crise économique actuelle toutes les
forces sont importantes pour relancer
l'économie les entreprises qui prêtent à
leurs partenaires au sein de la filière
j'évoquais la filière agricole ne
comprennent pas pourquoi ils ne
pouvaient pas bénéficier aussi de
garantie de l'état ou de l'europe par
l'abbé hui au même titre que les banques
ou les fonds elle tiff ou les
particuliers merci beaucoup nous en
avons terminé avec les questions au
gouvernement nos prochaines questions
auront lieu le mercredi 3 juin à 15
heures
merci monsieur le premier ministre
merci mesdames et messieurs les
ministres je vais suspendre notre
science et sa reprise à 16h15 pour un
débat dans le cadre de l'espace réservé
au groupe de l'union centriste
notre séance est suspendue elle
reprendra à 16h04 voilà pour cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement que vous avez pu suivre en
intégralité et en direct sur l'antenne
de public sénat
on va débriefer un toute cette séance
dans un instant une séance qui a été
largement consacrée bien sûr à la
question du coc vie de 19 est la
question est bien des conséquences
notamment des conséquences économiques
bien sûr de l'épidémie vous l'avez vu de
nombreuses questions notamment été
adressée au ministre de l'économie bruno
le maire je suis avec le président du
groupe
elle est réussie au sénat bruno
retailleau bonjour bruno retailleau
quelques questions d'actualité tout
d'abord et bien sûr l'identique
chloroquine à n'est plus autorisée en
france pour soigner le kobe 19 aces une
sage décision
bruno retailleau pour vous qui comptait
parmi les grands défenseurs des travaux
du professeur out
non je pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'études
il ya d'ailleurs la fameuse étude dans
la vie réelle du professeur out avec un
taux de mortalité qui est très faible 0
5%
donc il ya plein d'études de
le monde ya des études positives et
d'autres négatives j'observe que il ya
des études un peu sur papier qu'on
appelle big data avec des données etc et
d'autres études encore une fois dans la
vie réelle donc je préfère moi quand
même des études de la vie réelle et on
verra bien au bout du bout on fera le
point le compte de deux éléments quand
même de réponse la preuve le premier
élément c'est que moi j'ai toujours été
favorable à la prescription médicale
soit d'hôpital mais aussi par les
médecins généralistes est une liberté
fondamentale
il faut pas l'atteindre dans la mesure
où en plus cette molécule ça fait 80 ans
qu'elle existe
elle traite le paludisme et elle a été
utilisée par des millions et des
millions d'êtres humains dans le monde
et on ne connaît parfaitement les
contre-indications il faut les respecter
donc encore une fois ce n'est pas la
chloroquine qui tue c'est la pandémie
voilà il faut revenir à des choses assez
précise
il faut avoir le sens aussi bien sûr de
la mesure mais je pense que le débat
n'est pas à défendre les travaux du mais
je pense que le débat n'est pas clos et
ma position a toujours été de dire
attention sur une molécule qu'on connaît
depuis longtemps qui a eu des effets
bénéfiques que sur un certain nombre de
maladies pour traiter aussi le paludisme
et autres on n'a pas le droit de
l'écarter d'un revers de niort alors
qu'on a nationalisé à plus de 3000
passion à marseille qui ont été traitées
avec des résultats et ces résultats on
peut pas les mettre par dessus bord il
existe et ça c'est une étude dans la vie
réelle c'est pas une étude statistique
donc moi je dis qu à l'empirisme c'est
une voie de la recherche
il ya une autre voie plus ce jour d'hier
abstraite qui mérite aussi d'être mené à
bien
mais au bout du bout je vais vous dire
ce qui départagera les uns et les autres
c'est le nombre de morts voilà ce sont
des résultats concrets et tangibles
un autre sujet qui fait couler beaucoup
d'encre bruno retailleau si la
réouverture annoncée du puy du fou sur
intervention présidentielle en faveur de
philippe de villiers est ce que pour
vous c'est une bonne décision à ce que
vous jugez que c'est normal cette
intervention des manuels macron dans ce
dossier mais moi je pense pas que ce
soit pour une décision à 2001 pour tel
ou tel moi je suis favorable à ce qu'on
puisse dès confiné il faut que la vie en
france puisse reprendre au puy du fou
bien sûr mais aussi dans les festivals
et dans les autres parcs
je pense que d'autres parcs que le puy
du fou vendée ouvrir moi je pense que
notamment pour la vendée c'est
évidemment une bonne nouvelle
il ya un impact économique est important
et depuis le départ j'ai toujours
indiqué qu' on pouvait avec un certain
nombre de précautions j'avais parlé des
masques de toutes les mesures barrières
faire en sorte qu'on se déconfite
mais en même temps de façon sûre donc
laissons la vie reprendre ses droits
et je pense que c'est important en
vendée comme ailleurs mais vous entendez
aussi une partie du monde de la culture
qu'ils jugent être resté dans le flou et
qui jusqu'il ya deux poids deux mesures
avec cette annonce qui a concerné
uniquement puy du fou et mais le reste
du monde de la culture qui pour
l'instant ne sait pas même mais
j'attends du premier ministre justement
qu'il lève les doutes et qu' on puisse à
partir du 2 juin prochain puisque il
nous l'avait dit au moment de son débat
sur le déconfinement aussi bien
l'assemblée nationale qu' ici au sénat
qu'il y aura une nouvelle marche trois
semaines après le 11 mai et bien c'est
dans quelques jours et peut-être
prendra-t-il la parole d'ailleurs demain
moi ce que j'attends c'est que on est un
nouveau déconfinement qu'on a un petit
peu plus loin pour l'ensemble des parcs
b mais aussi des spectacles vivants en
général c'est important la culture je
pense que les français dont cette paille
de confinement ont besoin de prendre
l'air dans un sens bien sûr concret mais
aussi des instances figuratif
je pense que la culture c'est de se dé
confiné aussi une dernière question
bruno retailleau sur gérald darmanin que
l'on a entendu dans l'hémicycle tout à
l'heure élu maire de tourcoing et qui
pour l'instant reste d'un ministre on en
a eu la preuve est ce que vous pensez
que sa situation est normal de pouvoir
ainsi pour l'instant cumulée et bien son
poste de ministre et le fait d'être
maire de tourcoing je précise tout de
même qui hier le premier ministre a dit
qu'il va falloir choisir à un moment ou
un autre nom mais la situation n'est pas
normale est ce que j'observe c'est que
avec ce nouveau monde
en tout cas qui se présentent nouveau il
ya toujours des règles qui sont des
règles pour lui même qui ne valent que
pour lui même mais pas pour les autres
il ya deux poids deux mesures évidemment
on en fait campagne justement sur une
sorte de république exemplaire où on
pourrait peut cumuler ils l'ont exigé
des parlementaires et moi je pense que
ça n'est pas positif je préfère moi des
parlementaires députés ou sénateurs qui
soit enracinée sur le terrain là où on
connaît les réalités plutôt que des gens
qui sont désignés par les partis élus
voilà parce que ils accrochent à leurs
affiches électorales la photo du présent
république je préfère des gens qui ont
des mandats locaux
évidemment donc ce que j'attends là
aussi ce n'est pas la règle du deux
poids deux mesures mais c'est une même
règle pour tous c'est ça la république
mêmes règles pour tous merci beaucoup
bruno retailleau d'avoir répondu à mes
questions je vous le disais tout à
l'heure la dimension économique a été
très largement évoqués lors de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et notamment la dimension
européenne c'est d'ailleurs sur cette
question que se sont ouvertes et bien
c'est question je vous propose d'écouter
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure et bien
l'intervention de bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie qui a parlé et
bien de ce plan qui a été déclenchée par
la commission européenne que la
commission européenne veut mettre en
place
c'est un geste politique majeure un
geste de solidarité
oui nous allons donner plus à ceux qui
ont été touchés le plus par la crise du
bournat virus oui nous allons donner
plus à l'espagne et à l'italie
eh bien ça devrait être un motif de
fierté pour nous tous parce que ça veut
dire que nous savons et des chefs d état
qui sont les plus en difficulté on va
aider le plus ceux qui sont le plus en
difficulté ce sont les mots de bruno le
maire tout à leurs amis de montchalin
bon jour en jour votre réaction tout
d'abord à ce sujet à ce plan d' aide
exceptionnelle de 750 milliards d'euros
vous en félicite et je le suppose est un
tournant politique
c'est un tournant parce qu'on voit bien
que on en train de vivre une crise qui
est inédite qui extrêmement profonde
qu'aucun pays européen ne peut s'en
sortir seul ne peut sortir seule de
cette crise soit pour reconstruire
l'économie parce que la crise a été très
profond soi-même pour investir dans
l'avenir avait sur la transition
écologique investir pour sa jeunesse
investir pour les emplois et donc ce que
la france et l'allemagne ont mis dans le
débat il ya maintenant une semaine
c'est que il nous fallait passer un cap
de solidarité un câble de souveraineté m
de l'endettement en commun c'est un vrai
changement de paradigme c'est un
changement totalement inédit aux frais
révolution une révolution et c'est
surtout une étape très forte et donc ce
qu'a proposé aujourd'hui ours est la
fonte dn c'est à la fois effectivement
un plan de relance 750 milliards avec
500 milliards d'euros de dépenses
budgétaires et c'était une demande très
forte de la france et l'allemagne
ce qu'ils montrent que quand on a du
courage et qu'on prend ses
responsabilités et bien on peut mettre
l'europe en marche
et puis parallèlement elle a aussi
présenté et c'est très important
son projet de budget européen entre 2021
et 2027
parce que après le rebond il faudra
aussi penser à tous ces investissements
qui font notre souveraineté
que ce soit dans l'écologie dans le
domaine social ou dans le maine
industrielle et donc ce que j'ai à dire
aujourd'hui c'est que on a beaucoup de
gens souvent qu'ils critiquent l'europe
et donc à cela j'ai envie de dire voilà
quand on met du poids politique quand
mais de la volonté quand mais la
persévérance ce qu'ont mis à la fois le
présent la république et angela merkel
eh bien on peut faire avancer cette
europe et vous pouvez compter sur
l'engagement de tous pour qu'on trouve
un accord maintenant sur cette
transition dans les jours qui viennent
mais il n'ya pas encore l'accord des 27
et on sait que ça peut être bien sûr ça
la difficulté encore convaincre les
réticents l'autriche la suède le
danemark les pays-bas et bien sûr parce
que il faut maintenant que sur cette
proposition ambitieuse à la hauteur la
crise on est un accord le plus vite
possible un conseil européen mi juin et
donc tout notre travail maintenant tout
le travail qui va être le mien c'est de
s'assurer qu'on arrive au tour cette
proposition de florence et de budget
européen qui couvrent voyez presque dix
ans devant nous et bien qu'on soit à la
hauteur pour à la fois sauvegarder
l'emploi sauvegarder la transition est
donc être vraiment d'une capacité
d'investissement reconstruire après la
crise c'est essentiel mais investir
c'est tout aussi essentiel pour vous
faut-il des contreparties à ces aides
pour ces pays qui vont être massivement
aidées ont dit que l'italie l'espagne
notamment devraient se tailler la part
du lion
si aujourd'hui une affaire de politique
économique ou d'engagement évidemment il
faut qu'on soit cohérent on est en train
de créer un plan de résilience un plan
de reconstruction
on a vu dans beaucoup de nos pays ont le
vent en france notre système de santé a
montré des fragilités c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'on a un ségur de la santé oms
est pas le pré ministre et olivier
ferrand
on a vu que aussi aujourd'hui conseil
des ministres on a pris l'engagement de
créer tout un nouveau plan sur la prise
en charge du grand âge l'autonomie donc
on a des réformes à consentir et on voit
bien que ce plan d'investissement ce
plan de relance il faut qu'il soit
cohérent avec ses grandes réformes que
l'union européenne va nous permettre
d'accompagner et d'approfondir donc ya
pas de conditionnalité c'est pas l'un
sinon rien mais c'est vraiment s'assurer
que les réformes qu'on fait de nos
systèmes publics certains ont été
d'ailleurs on a vu les fragiles et dans
cette crise est bien là avec cet
investissement massif qu'on consent
maintenant il faut qu'on trouve un
accord et c'est tout le travail qu'on va
mener vraiment avec beaucoup
d'engagement et au gouvernement dans les
semaines qui viennent une toute dernière
question à mes livres
montchanin pour conclure sur votre
collègue gérald darmanin je posais tout
à l'heure la question à bruno retailleau
qui juge qu'il ya deux poids deux
mesures qu'ils puissent rester et bien
ministre et maire en même temps même si
je précise que hier d'un fils pas dit
qu'il faudrait certainement choisir à un
moment ou un autre
votre sentiment on sait bien que je
pense que le prêt ministre a raison nous
sommes dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles on a un maire qui est
lui qui est au plus proche de ses
électeurs dans sa commune qui est aussi
ministre
je pense qu'effectivement ça va durer un
temps mais je ne sais qui a duré très
longtemps jusqu'à nouvel ordre
voyez bien que c'est pas à la ministre
des affaires aux européennes de se
prononcer sur cette question je pense
que c'est très important qu'on ait tous
d'ailleurs nous ministre toujours un
lien très fort avec un territoire c'est
que j'étais parlementaire et lui en
essonne
c'est aussi pour moi quelque chose de
très important mettant en jeu les cumuls
pas par définition mais c'est très
important que quand on est au
gouvernement on puisse avoir ce lien au
territoire
parce que bien c'est là c'est pour les
citoyens c'est pour les français qu'on
travaille et donc ça me semble être au
fond un fondement de mon engagement
également merci beaucoup à mélanger
répondu à mes questions on poursuit les
interviews j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
le président du groupe socialiste au
sénat patrick kanner m'écoutais je vais
commencer par vous poser la même
question vous quel est votre avis sur la
situation de cumul de gérald darmanin
côté monsieur darmana ministre il est
maintenant mr bientôt conseiller
métropolitain et conseiller régional
donc ça veut dire qu'il a une grande
force de travail bon dont acte
moi j'ai appartenu à un gouvernement où
on ne pouvait pas être ministre et
membre d'un exécutif et j'ai respecté
cette conquête sorel d'un cumul des
mandats qui a été créé dans les majeures
ce pince jospin en 95 qui attend 17
pardon qui a décidé qu'un ministre
devait se consacrer pleinement à
l'action de la république et aux
services de l'état
voilà chacun a sa conception de son
investissement au profit de l'état alors
peut-être un canard en va également
parler et bien de ce plan pour
l'automobile
et puis notamment la situation de
renault irm annuel macron alliés a
conditionné le prêt de 5 milliards
d'euros de l'état renault à des
garanties pour les salariés de douai et
de maubeuge
est ce pour vous une bonne nouvelle est
ce pour vous suffisant c'est une bonne
approche que de donner des aides d'état
sous réserve que
la préoccupation de l'emploi soient
prises en considération par les
entreprises donc je salue cette mise en
condition après il faut la mettre en
oeuvre et c'est toute la question qui
est posée et moi-même tout samedi
prochain je serai sûrement ça mc a donc
à maubeuge pour vérifier que les
engagements de l'état seront bien tenu
par l'entreprise crois que c'est très
important aujourd'hui que le monde
l'entreprise sache que quand il y a
l'argent public c'est l'argent de tout
ce qui est consacré pour sauver neuf
cent mille emplois dans le secteur de
l'automobile
et bien il y à des conditions fixées par
les autorités
et moi je suis favorable à ce que ces
conditions soient non seulement émises
mais surtout qu'on ait les moyens de les
mettre en oeuvre il ya eu les dividendes
qui ont été visées de façon très claire
dès la loi mais il n'y a pas eu cette
dimension sociale est ce que vous
continuez à vouloir l'inscrire on sait
qu'il y aura notamment un projet de loi
de finances rectificative numéro 3 en
préparation derrière la question
d'automobiles se pose la question de
l'augmentation du chômage en général
dans notre pays françois hollande disait
il y à 48 heures qu'on pouvait
malheureusement craindre un million de
chômeurs de longue durée en plus dans
les quelques mois peut-être les quelques
semaines qui arrivent et donc j'ai
toujours réclamée avec un collègue du
groupe socialiste non seulement un état
d'urgence sanitaire mais aussi un état
d'urgence sanitaire et sociale est
aujourd'hui le compte n'y est pas on le
voit bien
et donc de moules loi en loi nous
proposons des amendements qui sont
systématiquement repoussé par la
majorité ou de droite ou de ré et
parfois c'est la même chose donc je le
regrette et nous continuerons néanmoins
à défendre celles et ceux qui
aujourd'hui craignent pour leur avenir
un autre amendement qui a été rejetée
hier dans l'hémicycle c'est un
amendement proposant la reprise des
compétitions professionnelles sous
conditions c'est un amendement de vos
collègues sénateurs le gouvernement
d'ailleurs s'est félicité du fait que
cet amendement n'avait pas été adoptée
qu'en pense l'ancien ministre des sports
que vous avez vous savez j'ai dans la
musique j'ai porté une voix négatives
par rapport à cet amendement parce que
je considère qu'il est potentiellement
juste mais trop tard on ne peut pas
revenir en arrière la décision a été
très brutale de la part du premier
ministre le 28 avril on arrête toutes
les compétitions sportives à caractère
professionnel
ça n'a pas été le cas de beaucoup de nos
voisins européens justement qui
reprennent aujourd'hui les compétitions
donc c'est une décision autoritaire
brutale assumer d'ailleurs par la
ministre
des sports je le regrette on aurait dû
peut-être suspendre les compétitions et
se poser la question aujourd'hui de les
remettre dans le circuit
cet amendement malheureusement ne
pouvait pas convenir aux fédérations et
aux ligues qui avait déjà prises
leur disposition pour reporter les
échéances en septembre mais globalement
le sport français est aujourd'hui au
point mort
je le regrette une décision beaucoup
trop rapide du gouvernement sur le sujet
qu'est ce que vous pensez de tout d'un
certain nombre de matchs sauvage dont
les médias se font les échos qui sont
sources pour le coup de rassemblements
non maîtrisée je les condamne
il ne respecte pas les conditions
sanitaires qui s'imposent aujourd'hui à
tout le pays et à chacun et à chacune
d'entre nous mais cela démontre quand
même l'aspiration des jeunes à pouvoir
reprendre une vie normale et donc je le
dis très solennellement la ministre des
sports doit encourager la reprise des
manifestations sportives dans les
meilleurs délais peut-être pas les
matches professionnels
ça c'est clair aujourd'hui c'est fini
malheureusement je le regrette mais dans
toutes les autres hypothèses
il faut que le sport puisse à nouveau
être une forme d'espoir pour tous les
français une toute toute dernière
question patrick kanner est ce que vous
avez trouvé un accord avec l'exécutif
pour pouvoir aborder la semaine
prochaine dans votre niche parlementaire
les sujets que vous souhaitiez abordé à
savoir la contribution des grandes
fortunes et le fonds d'indemnisation des
victimes du coc vide
non la réponse est clairement non le
ministre marc fesneau a confirmé tout à
l'heure en conférence des présidents au
sénat que le gouvernement n'engagerait
pas la procédure accélérée à notre
profit parce qu'il est contre les deux
propositions de loi dont une censure
politique c'est un droit constitutionnel
de la part du gouvernement
il aurait pu lever ce gage comme témoin
l'expression il ne l'a pas fait c'est
son choix je le respecte mais je les
dénonçait comme étant une forme d'une
élégance à l'égard de l'opposition si le
gouvernement pense que c'est en
maltraitant sur l'opposition qu'il fera
avancer les choses ils se trompent
eh bien merci beaucoup patrick kanner
d'avoir répondu à mes questions je
représente accueillir le sénateur
communiste des hauts-de-seine pierre aux
liasses bon jour on vous a entendu tout
à l'heure à interpeller le gouvernement
et bien sûr la question de la culture
sur portant ainsi ce cri d'alarmé du
monde de la culture
normalement on devrait avoir des
annonces très rapidement vous êtes
encore très sains
patient car auzias ah non je suis plus
impatients là c'est fini j'ai entendu le
ministre on a bien compris qu'il n'y
aurait pas de deux plans de sauvetage de
la culture mais une succession de
mesurettes de toutes petites mesures qui
sont pas du tout adaptés les
intermittents il ya eu pas complète il
ya eu des mesures pour les intermittents
mais pas complète
il ya une partie des intermittents qui
sont pas pris dans le dispositif et il
ya très peu de choses pour les salles de
spectacles pour les fêtes et festivals
etc etc donc plus que ce que la culture
voulais c'était un plan un grand plan
global comme il y en a pour l'automobile
le tourisme et là ils vont être obligés
de se contenter de vagues promesses dans
la vienne à l'esprit est que c'est une
industrie importante fournie d'aisance
et de l'industrie et pour beaucoup de
nos concitoyens c'est un supplément
d'âme c'est pas c'est pas une petite
chose c'est constitutif aussi de notre
de notre identité 2 français 2 française
donc c'est vraiment risque en période de
crise comme celle que nous vivons s'y
intéresse pas plus alors est ce que vous
vous réjouissez néanmoins de la
réouverture du puy du fou
dans ce contexte pierre rosalia ce jeu
je suis très surpris que alors que
moi j'habite par exemple les
hauts-de-seine je peux pas me rendre
dans le parc que juste à côté de chez
moi
le puy du fou ouvre dès le 2 dès le 2
juin et que on interdise la vraie traque
ce ne sont pas les mêmes zones non mais
peut-être mais mais j'ai vraiment
l'impression que c'est le fait du prince
il ya une décision qui a été prise
directement par le président on
conseille de défense ce qui est quand
même pas l'organisme le plus approprié
pour parler de deux cultures et là on
voit très bien que c'est la relation
amicale entre deux personnages qui a
permis une dérogation très très larges
ce que vous savez bien que aujourd'hui
même dans le vestiaire sera philippe dé
villiers et manière conjointe sur ce que
même dans les zones vertes on peut pas
se réunira plus de 15000 je pense pas
que ça soit la fréquentation du
puy-du-fou pause elias autre sujet qui
vous tient à coeur cette ce sujet c'est
le passage aux études supérieures et
notamment parcours support sur lequel
vous travaillez depuis que vous êtes
parlement depuis toujours
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui dans
cette période extrêmement particulière
marquée par le confinement le
déconfinement et bien pour tous ces
lycéens qui doivent passer bien au
niveau supérieur pour l'année prochaine
alors les les premiers chiffres qui sont
à notre disposition montrent de façon
assez assez clair que parcours sup a été
cette année plus sélectif encore que
l'an passé par exemple pour pour la
première journée de retour d information
pour les candidats il y avait plus de
40% des jeunes qui n'avaient aucune
proposition aucune proposition 1 c'est
comment l'expliquer par leurs terres aux
six normales pris par les universités
dans cette période parce qu'il ya deux
choses d'une part la suppression de fait
du bac à renforcer la sélection des
dossiers sur les notes de contrôle
continu du lycée voilà et je pense que
la dématérialisation complète de la
sélection des dossiers à favoriser
l'utilisation d'algorithmes et il ya eu
moins d'humains - d'humain dans dans
l'analyse des dossiers ce qui ce qui
fait tout ce qu'a toujours comme pour
conséquence une plus grande sélectivité
un mot enfin pierre ausonia ce serait
bien ce déconfinement à l'école jean
michel blanquer appelle les parents qui
pourraient être réticents à envoyer
leurs enfants à l'école
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec lui
je pense que aujourd'hui oui c'est
absolument indispensable que les enfants
les collégiens les lycéens retrouve le
chemin des classes
c'est nécessaire d'un point de vue
social pour eux d'un point de vue
intellectuel est bon maintenant les
données médicales que nous avons
montrent que ce sont pas les enfants qui
sont les plus sujets à ce virus gens
n'aiment pas d'accord avec le ministre
de l'éducation nationale merci beaucoup
brésil y'a ce d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
encore une interview à venir mais je
vous propose de revenir à l'un des temps
forts de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
l'exécutif a notamment été questionnés
et bien sûr l'organisation des élections
municipales vous le savez elles doivent
se tenir le 28 juin
écoutez le secrétaire d'état lors en
ligne est ce au moment même où on se
parle et je viens d'ailleurs de quitter
cette réunion que je vais rejoindre
aussitôt nous recevons avec le ministre
de l'intérieur dit d'autres ministres
les chefs des partis politiques de notre
pays puis nous aurons une réunion
ensuite avec les associations d'élus
pour discuter de ce que seront ces
modalités qui permettront je reprends
vos propos madame la sénatrice
d'organiser ces élections dans des
conditions irréprochables à la fois en
termes juridiques et à la fois en termes
bien évidemment de protection sanitaire
de nos concitoyens alors bien sûr
plusieurs pistes seront évoqués le fait
de faciliter les procurations le fait de
préconiser d'avoir la possibilité pour
les électeurs de pouvoir porter
effectivement un masque l'aménagement
des bureaux de vote comme nous l'avions
fait en partie pour le premier tour mais
d'autres préconisations est émise par le
conseil scientifique et nous travaillons
évidemment à la mise en oeuvre de ces
dispositifs
et je suis avec sophie primas sénatrice
les républicains des yvelines présidente
de la commission des affaires
économiques du jour sont donc jumaa un
mot tout d'abord de réactions face et
bien à l'annoncé de ces élections qui
vont se tenir le 28 juin quelle
difficulté vous voyez vous face à vous
écouter je crois que tout le monde a en
tête effectivement la participation et
les difficultés liées à la crise
sanitaire
maintenant fin juin c'est quand même
dans deux mois donc je pense que les
choses vont évoluer sur le territoire et
je crois qu'il y est présente dans un
mois pardon dans un mois pardon je vois
là je vis à vis être vite et et c'est
dans un mois je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'autorisations qui vont être qu'ils
vont être la passion pour la sincérité
du scrutin néanmoins oui certains moi je
pense qu'on est dans une phase de
déconfinement on est on est dans une
phase nouvelle qui est plutôt une phase
optimiste donc moi je suis plus
optimiste que certains sur la
participation parce que je crois que
l'attachement au maire est quelque chose
de très fort dans la population
contrairement à ce qu'on dit je pense
que les gens ont envie de se déplacer et
comme on est plutôt dans une phase de
déconfinement que dans une phase de
confinement
voilà je suis plus optimiste à condition
qu'on mette en place les conditions pour
réussir et c'est l'objet de la
proposition de philippe bas d'hervé
marseille bruno retailleau effectivement
sophie primas la semaine dernière vous
posiez une question sur la situation de
renault depuis bien il ya eu le plan
automobile annoncées hier par emmanuel
macron et puis cette annonce un
spécifique sur renault le président de
la république qui a conditionné en
quelque sorte les 5 milliards d'euros de
prêts de l'état à des garanties pour les
sites de douai et pour les sites de
maubeuge
est ce pour vous une bonne chose une
bonne solution je pense que le fait que
le président de la république demande
des contreparties et des engagements à
renault et sur le principe une bonne
chose vous comprendrez bien que l'élu
des yvelines que je suis à un oeil
particulier sur l' usine renault flins
vous auriez préféré pour flore c'est pas
que j'aurais préféré sur flins mais le
site de renault flins est un site
emblématique de la transition de renault
vers des véhicules propres ou en tout
cas vers des véhicules électriques
donc je vais avoir beaucoup beaucoup de
mal on a beaucoup de mal à m'expliquer
la transformation du site de flins voire
pire pour le site de flins en plein
milieu d'une conditionnalité sur un pg e
2,5 milliards d'euros qui fait
pratiquement les trois quarts de l'air
antilles pour flins du coup également
je demande des garanties et je demande
surtout de la cohérence et je demande
qui ait pas d'ambiguïté sur le devenir
industriel et pérenne du site de flins
ont fait des véhicules des objets de
mobilité à flins depuis 1952
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui avec la zoé
n'ont rien à voir avec ce qu'on faisait
en 1952 évidemment donc c'est un site
qui a su évoluer
c'est un site auquel également les
collectivités territoriales ont mainte
faits ont maintes fois pardon fait
référence si on essayait d'aider pour
améliorer la compétitivité du site
on a tendu la main très très souvent à
renault aujourd'hui il faut qu'ils
attrapent cette main et qui nous
laissent les aider à faire de ce site un
site compétitif une toute dernière
question selon l'insee l'activité va se
contracter de 20 % au deuxième trimestre
qu'est ce que vous craignez vous pour la
suite est-ce que vous craignez
l'écroulement des vagues de
licenciements on le sait pour l'instant
l'économie est encore sous perfusion
oui l'économie est sous perfusion et je
pense qu'on a on commence à voir les
premiers soubresauts des difficultés moi
je crains la cascade voyez par exemple
si on reprend l'exemple du site renault
flins derrière c'est une cascade de sous
traitance et des relations avec l'usiné
peugeot de poissy enfin voilà ce que je
crains c'est cette cascade là qui une
fois qu'elle est partie vous savez c'est
un peu comme les jeux de dominos est
difficile à arrêter
merci beaucoup sophie primas d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
c'est la fin de cette émission c'est la
fin de ce débrief des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement tout de
suite et bien en place à l'assemblée
nationale et au débat sur ce top cow
vide
quant à moi je me retrouve tout à
l'heure à 21h15 pour ce même débat stop
qu'ovide mais cette fois ci au sénat
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]